la promesse est simple à l'aide d'une
application téléchargée sur son portable
le consommateur voit apparaître tout
l'historique du produit depuis sa
plantation en passant par l'identité du
producteur une initiative appréciée par
les consommateurs vigiles vous poser la
question quand vous achetez à bien sûr
moi j'ai un concert hommage produits
locaux c'est fini maintenant là moi je
n'achète que des produits qui sont faits
a menti qui sont cultivés au martinique
la séparation ce label pur j'ai un test
et on verra bien
vous allez sortir une différence quand
vous dites que vous tester mon corps va
réagir on verra bien à terme le label 0
chlordécone devrait être affiché dans la
plupart des marchés et grandes surfaces
500 agriculteurs pourraient être
labellisés contre une cinquantaine
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs locaux qui
pourront ainsi valoriser leur production
l'aïe ont commencé par les du
chlordécone à 2006 marque est la vote
moi baissé et comme tout moun ka mandé -
là sa sortie la tap a senti et m'a dit
qu'a justement demeco magnanou préfet
pouvait semoun en colonie des produits
c'est martin et puis ça c'est pas tout
tort déconner et comme failli racheter
et les moutons palais dit l'abbé la
mondiale voilà mon affaire manqué
labellisé produits - papa kenya ballet
et ses moulins le jacquot net - léocadie
confiance et le crédit h et s'est
produit à rétablir la confiance c'est un
peu le credo du parc naturel en charge
du respect du cahier des charges du
label qui s'étendra prochainement
c'est un organisme indépendant qui ne
dépend pas du parc naturel de martinique
donc sept organisent à un agrément et
cet agrément lui permet d'accréditer
après analyse des produits et de la
production
ça se fait dans des laboratoires dans la
drôme qui permettent aujourd'hui de dire
que cet aliment ne contient pas de
résidu d'os chlordécone une étape de
plus vers l'exigence du zéro chlordécone
pour l'ensemble de la production
martiniquaise lorsque l'état décidera de
ne plus tolérer les moindres résidus
dans l'alimentation
ce label n'aura plus lieu d'être mais
nous n'en sommes pas encore là